does running really damage your knees
many people fear that the repetitive
stress and impact from running can
potentially lead to knee damage and
long-term joint problems however is this
concern based on fact or fiction regular
running helps to strengthen the muscles
around the knee joint such as the
quadriceps and the hamstrings these
muscles act as shock absorbers reducing
the stress placed on the knees during
physical activities by providing
enhanced support they help to minimize
the risk of knee injuries and improves
The Joint stability contrary to popular
belief scientific research suggests that
running when practiced correctly and
with proper precautions does not
inherently damage your knees in fact
running can offer several benefits to
the knee health and overall joint
function running also helps in managing
weight and reducing chances of obesity
excess weight can place additional
strain on the joints including the knees
which increases the risk of joint
problems and conditions such as
osteoarthritis